.
* Vielstimmiges Bellen *
* Winseln *
(Frau) Der Hund hat keine Nase.
Das ist Qualzucht pur.
* Sie spricht unverständlich. *
In vier Wochen kann man die abholen.
- Aha.
Die sind viel zu jung, wenn man sie
von Mutter und Geschwistern trennt
und sie
in eine fremde Umgebung kommen.
Diese Autofahrt ist Stress pur
und damit viel zu viel
für die jungen Welpen.
Ihr Immunsystem
ist noch unterentwickelt.
Wir machen eine Kontrolle.
Nehmen Sie bitte Geld und Telefon
mit und kommen Sie mit uns rein.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Das Geburtsdatum wurde massiv
manipuliert. Das geht nicht.
Woher kommen Sie jetzt?
- Nix Deutsch.
Es ist eine Welpenmafia,
vergleichbar mit dem Drogenhandel.
Damit werden
unglaubliche Summen verdient.
Sie können die Strafe erklären.
- Ich habe genug.
Sie haben die Tiere
zu wenig getränkt und gefüttert.
Das ist nicht normal,
verdammt noch mal.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Piepstöne *
(Frau) Rocky hat gestern
Medikamente erbrochen.
* Jaulen *
Die kamen heute
in den Notfall zu uns.
Sie wurden beide
aus Kroatien importiert.
Die beiden Welpen
sind Geschwistertiere.
Der Hündin geht es sehr schlecht.
Jetzt gehen wir
in die Intensivstation rein.
Sie sehen schon,
wir haben immer mehr Absperrungen,
weil wir
immer mehr Seuchentiere haben.
Seuchentiere.
Meist haben sie Parvovirose.
Eine gefährliche Virenkrankheit -
unbehandelt sterben die Welpen.
Die Hunde stecken sich oft
auf dem Transport in die Schweiz an.
Diese kranken Welpen
gab's schon immer.
Aber das momentane Ausmass
ist absolut ...
Es ist sehr grenzwertig.
So schlimm wie im Moment
habe ich es noch nie erlebt.
Seit Montag waren es fünf Welpen.
Einer pro Tag.
Extrem viele Leute
legen sich jetzt Hunde zu.
Das ist wohl bedingt
durch die Coronakrise.
* Piepston *
Was ist das?
Die Infusion läuft nicht.
Ist das schlecht?
Nein, es kann sein,
dass sein Pfötchen umgeknickt ist.
Je jünger die Welpen,
desto weniger Immunschutz,
desto eher werden sie krank.
Wie alt ist dieses Tier?
Das ist jetzt acht Wochen
und sechs Tage alt.
Also die Mindestzeit, dass man es
überhaupt importieren darf?- Genau.
Aber ist es denn richtig?
Ja, da unten.
Ist es schon abgebrochen, oh je.
Frau Reichler, ist das zu jung,
weil sie schnell erkranken?
Vom Gesetz her
wurden sie korrekt importiert.
Für mich sind sie klar zu jung.
Die Jungtiere sind sehr anfällig.
Hören Sie, jetzt hustet sie
auch noch. Gell, Schnecke.
Jetzt hat sie sich wahrscheinlich
beim Erbrechen verschluckt.
Die Schweizer Acht-Wochen-Regel
ist viel weniger streng
als jene in fast allen
westeuropäischen Ländern.
Dort müssen Welpen
mind. 15 Wochen alt sein,
bis sie importiert werden dürfen.
So.
- Hallo zusammen.
Es tut mir leid.
Wir haben gesagt, dass wir
die Blutergebnisse abwarten.
Die Blutergebnisse sind nicht gut.
D.h., wir haben bei Rocky und Sky
Parvovirose, diese Hundeseuche.
Ich kann nicht versprechen,
dass beide überleben.- Mhm.
Für die Behandlung
müssen Sie für beide zusammen
mit deutlich über 7'000 Fr. rechnen.
Aber wenn Sie sich die Behandlung
nicht leisten können,
müssen Sie es mir frühzeitig sagen.
Sky und Rocky kosteten 1'200 Euro.
Kann der Besitzer ihre Behandlung
nicht bezahlen,
müssen sie eingeschläfert werden.
Er will die Summe in Raten abzahlen.
Gut.
Frau Bauer, das ist ...
* Piepston *
Hallo.
Nennen wir das Mädchen Sophie.
Ihre Eltern
haben einen Zwergspitz bestellt.
Wo habt ihr ihn gesucht?
Eigentlich überall ...
... im Internet.
Im Internet.
Wie kam der Hund hierher?
Mit dem Auto.
Kam er zu euch nach Hause?
Nein.
Wir haben uns auf einem Parkplatz
einer Raststätte getroffen.
Sophies Hund hat keinen Chip,
ist also illegal.
Und schlimmer noch:
Er stammt vermutlich aus Moldawien.
Ein Land mit Tollwutgefahr.
Welche Krankheit soll nicht
in die Schweiz gebracht werden?
Hast du das verstanden?
Ich möchte es nicht sagen.
- Mhm.
* Fiepen *
Jetzt geht's schon etwas besser.
Er kann den Kopf halten.
Der ist süss.
Bei Tollwutgefahr
werden viele Hunde eingeschläfert.
Aber der Kantonstierarzt
hat eine Ausnahme gemacht
und eine Quarantäne
für Sophies Welpen angeordnet.
Es wird sich herausstellen,
dass das Tier keine Tollwut hat.
Die Zahl der wegen Tollwutgefahr
eingeschläferten Hunde aber
hat sich in den letzten zehn Jahren
mehr als verdoppelt.
Haben Sie es schon mal erlebt,
dass so ein Hund
eingeschläfert werden musste?
Ja, das musste ich schon machen.
Das ist furchtbar.
Das ist für mich ein Albtraum.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Ich warte auf den Amtstierarzt
von St. Gallen.
Guten Morgen.
- Herr Diener, freut mich.
Matthias Diener wird gerufen,
wenn mit einem importierten Hund
etwas nicht stimmt.
Z.B., wenn der Zoll einen Hunde-
transport aus Osteuropa kontrolliert
und sieht,
dass die Tiere keine Pässe haben
und somit illegal ins Land kommen.
Wir haben ein, zwei
komplexere, illegale Importfälle
pro Woche, die wir bearbeiteten.
Pro Woche zwei Fälle?
- Ja, ein, zwei Fälle.
Das ist viel.
Ich sage dazu gerne
Zalando-Mentalität.
Man bestellt online, lässt es sich
vor die Haustür liefern,
und wenn es nicht gefällt,
schickt man es wieder zurück.
Wie finden Sie das?
- Eine Katastrophe.
Ich finde es ganz schlimm.
Letztes Jahr wurden fast
31'000 importierte Hunde registriert,
eine Rekordzahl.
Dazu kommen die illegalen Importe -
laut Zoll
letztes Jahr mind. 7'600 Hunde.
Ist das der Hintereingang?
- Der Lieferanteneingang.
Im Moment
gibt es v.a. eine Organisation,
mit der wir grosse Probleme haben:
die Firma Elitdog aus der Slowakei
mit dem Transportunternehmen
Taktik s.r.o.
Das läuft alle 14 Tage ab.
Es kommt immer das gleiche Fahrzeug
an die St. Galler Grenze.
Das Problem ist,
dass die mit manipulierten Ausweisen
kommen, Heimtierpässen.
Hier sind ein paar Beispiele:
Das ist
ein slowakischer Heimtierpass,
mit dem Ausstellungsdatum
Wenn man den Pass
einfach so anschaut, sieht man das.
Wenn er nicht unter einem speziellen
Licht angeschaut wird,
sieht man 22.02.2021.
Die Firma Elitdog
mache Urkundenfälschung.
Gleich wie ein Mensch hat
ein Hund einen Pass, seine Identität.
Vermutlich geht es um Kosten.
Der Hundehandel
ist ein Riesengeschäft.
Wir vermuten, dass so ein Pass
ein paar Franken kostet.
Das kann man unter Umständen
günstiger machen,
indem man einen Pass eines Hundes,
den man nicht platzieren konnte,
überschreibt.
Noch tragischer sind für mich
die Bilder bei Impfungen.
Es wird auch
bei Impfungen manipuliert.
D.h, das ist Betrug,
hier wurde nicht geimpft?
Ich hoffe, dass geimpft wurde.
Ich weiss es aber nicht genau.
Als wir sahen,
dass hier massiv manipuliert wurde,
entschieden wir, die Tiere
vorübergehend zu beschlagnahmen.
Ich holte die Hunde beim Zoll
und deponierte sie in
einem Tierheim im Kanton St. Gallen.
* Hecheln *
Ich dachte,
ich sehe den Hund nie wieder.
Ich hatte schlaflose Nächte.
Die Unsicherheit war ständig da.
- Weil der Hund beschlagnahmt wurde?
Ja, ich wusste am Anfang nicht,
aus welchem Grund.
Andiamo, Charlye, bravo.
Charlye,
ein Shiba-Inu-Welpe von Elitdog.
Bestellt von Anthony Motta.
Dessen Eignung wurde
vom St. Galler Tierheim abgeklärt,
bevor er den Hund bekam.
Wie kamen Sie darauf,
Charlye im Internet zu kaufen
und nicht in der Schweiz?
Ich habe in der Schweiz geschaut.
Leider ist die Nachfrage
nach der Shiba-Inu-Rasse sehr hoch.
Die Wartezeit
wäre fünf, sechs Monate gewesen.
Das wäre nicht gegangen?
Nicht wegen des Wartens.
Wir haben gespürt, dass wir
wieder einen Welpen brauchen.
Selbstkritisch gesagt: Wenn Sie
ein Tier wollen, dann schnell?
Es soll funken -
wie Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Das war bei Charlye wirklich so.
Ich sah sein Inserat,
und ab dann gab es nur noch ihn.
Aber haben Sie den Hund bekommen,
den Sie im Inserat gesehen haben?
Das ist die andere Frage.
Mit solchen Videos
verkauft Elitdog Welpen.
Ich wollte ein Weibchen.
Und vor dem Transportdatum
hiess es dann plötzlich:
"Wir haben ein Problem.
Es ist ein Männchen."
Ich wollte nicht reklamieren.
Wer im Internet
nach "Welpen kaufen" sucht,
gelangt auf die Seite welpenkaufen.ch
der Firma Elitdog in der Slowakei.
Elitdog besitzt auch
die Domaine welpenkaufen.at,
weil sie auch Hunde
nach Österreich verkauft.
Man kann runterscrollen
wie auf Zalando.
Man möchte einen Hund
mit blauen Augen.
Man kann auf eigenen Wunsch
einen Hund zusammenstellen.
Am Anfang
sah es für mich seriös aus.
Ich hatte telefonischen Kontakt
mit einer Person.
Mit wem? Wie heisst die Frau?
Ich habe nie nach Namen gefragt.
Sie gab mir Sicherheit.
- Was gab Ihnen Sicherheit?
Sie sagte mir z.B., dass wir
erst zahlen, wenn der Hund hier ist.
Es hiess,
ich solle meine Adresse angeben.
Drei Tage später wurde er versendet.
Versendet?
Also transportiert.
Als ob es ein Postauto wäre.
Vieni qui.
Amore. Charlyno,
vieni qua, bello di mamma.
Dai, dai, vieni, dai.
Ja.
Vieni qua, vieni, vieni.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Gibt es einem zu denken,
dass man mit einer mutmasslich
kriminellen Organisation
zusammengearbeitet hat?
Absolut. Das gab mir zu denken.
Klar, der Welpe ist bei mir.
Aber was und wen
habe ich mit dem Geld unterstützt?
sie haben noch den Hund gesehen
und den Verstand ausgeschaltet?
Genau, das ist richtig.
(Durchsage) Meine Damen und Herren,
Guten Morgen aus dem Cockpit.
Herr T.: Besitzer von Elitdog.
In der Slowakei heisst
seine Hundehandelsfirma Taktik,
gegründet 2007.
T. in seinem Jacuzzi,
gefilmt vom slowakischen Fernsehen.
955 Welpen
exportierte er letztes Jahr
laut slowakischer Veterinärbehörde.
Die meisten Hundepässe hat
ein einziger Tierarzt ausgestellt:
Doktor K.
Im Pandemiejahr 2020 verdoppelte die
Hundehandelsfirma Taktik ihren Umsatz
auf über eine halbe Million Euro.
Bei 955 exportierten Hunden
und einem durchschnittlichen Ver-
kaufspreis von 1'200 Euro pro Hund
ohne Mehrwertsteuer
hat Taktik aber
rund 1 Mio. Umsatz gemacht.
Also rund doppelt so viel
wie die Firma meldet.
1 Std. von der slowakischen
Hauptstadt entfernt liegt Balon,
ein 700-Seelen-Dorf
im Süden des Landes.
Wir filmen versteckt.
Hier am Geschäftssitz von Elitdog
und Taktik
haben wir uns
als Kaufinteressenten angemeldet.
Als Erstes fällt mir auf:
der weisse Citroën Berlingo.
Ich erkenne das Nummernschild.
Damit wurden Welpen transportiert,
die in St. Gallen
beschlagnahmt wurden.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich habe keine Maske,
aber ich bin geimpft. - Wir auch.
Die Frau, die uns begrüsst,
heisst angeblich Julia.
Es ist dieselbe Person,
die ich auf den Videos
der Hundekäufer gesehen habe.
Schön, es ist gross.
Im Vergleich zu den Häusern in der
Umgebung ist dieses Anwesen luxuriös.
In der Ferne sehen wir Zwinger
mit rund einem Dutzend Hunden.
Insider sagen, Elitdog
züchte max. 10 % der Welpen,
die die Firma verkaufe.
Der Rest werde zugekauft.
Julia führt uns zu einem Käfig
mit zwei Malteser-Welpen.
Sie seien zwölf Wochen alt.
Zu jung für den Export
in viele EU-Länder.
Elitdog nützt die schwachen Gesetze
der Schweiz und Österreichs aus
und verkauft die Hunde
fast nur dorthin.
Allerdings verschärft Österreich
auf Ende Jahr sein Gesetz.
Wollen wir noch andere sehen?
Zwergspitz?
Hier. Aber ich möchte
nicht so viel raus und rein.
Ich frage mich:
Sind keine Zwergspitze vor Ort?
Oder könnten sie
im hinteren Teil dieses Hauses sein -
in solchen Boxen?
So wurden Welpen
vor vier Jahren gehalten,
vor einem Grosstransport
nach Belgien.
Das belgische Fernsehen
hat damals versteckt im Haus gedreht.
Könnte etwas passieren
auf dem Transport,
weil sie noch so jung sind?
- Was kann passieren?
Wenn man sie wegnimmt von hier,
von der Mama, dass sie krank werden?
Wie kann das sein?
Wenn Sie ein Kind haben und in den
Urlaub fahren, werden die krank?
Es kann nichts passieren?
- Nein.
* Der Welpe fiept. *
Wie sind Sie zu diesem Hund gekommen?
Meine Frau
ging auf eine Internetseite.
Ich glaube, die heisst Elitdog.
Also, Chica ...
... hat Parvovirose.
Sie wurde bestellt und geliefert.
Sie sagten,
sie liefern bis vor die Haustür.
Wegen des Coronavirus konnten sie
nicht in die Schweiz einreisen,
sondern nur
bis zur österreichischen Grenze.
Der Transport mit Chica
fand einen Monat nach der
Beschlagnahmung in St. Gallen statt.
Chica wurden von ihren Käufern
über die Schweizer Grenze gebracht.
Bei gefälschten Papieren
hätten sie gehaftet.
Wie viel hat der Hund gekostet?
1'300.
- Euro?- Ja.
Ist das teuer oder angemessen?
Es ist nicht teuer
im Verhältnis zur Schweiz.
Wie viel zahlt man hier?
Hier zahlt man sicher das Doppelte.
Chica war auf einem Transport
mit vier anderen Hunden.
Auch dieser Malteser war dabei: Lars.
Auch hier blutig-wässriger Durchfall.
Auch Lars hat Parvovirose.
Hier zeigt sich das Problem:
Sehr junge Welpen
aus mutmasslich schlechten Zuchten
mit wenig Immunschutz
werden zusammen transportiert
und stecken sich vermutlich
gegenseitig an.
Der Käufer von Lars aber will
nicht für seine Behandlung zahlen.
Es ging nur ums Geld
und nicht um den Hund.
Direkt nach der Abgabe
wurde noch mal gefragt,
ob wir eine Seite empfehlen können,
wo man einen Hund adoptieren kann.
Also: Dieser Hund ist krank,
also will man den nächsten?
Genau.
- Wie ist das für Sie?
Das ist extrem frustrierend.
Das macht extrem wütend.
Man muss aufpassen, wie man
mit diesem Leuten kommuniziert,
damit man nicht unfair wird.
Wir geben unser Bestes.
Das macht einen so traurig,
wütend und einfach müde.
Lars hat Glück im Unglück:
Kollegen der Tierärztinnen
übernehmen ihn und seine Kosten.
Der Besitzer wollte, dass der Hund
stirbt, dass man ihn einschläfert,
damit er keine Kosten mehr hat?
Das wäre sein Wunsch gewesen?
Ja. Es ist einfach unverantwortlich
und egoistisch.
Rund jeder fünfte Hund im Zürcher
Tierspital stamme von Elitdog,
sagen die Ärztinnen.
Hat man Ihnen die Kosten gesagt?
Wenn er eine Bluttransfusion bekommt
sind es 5'000-7'000 Fr.
Mehr, als wenn man den Hund
in der Schweiz gekauft hätte?- Ja.
Woher aber stammen Chica und die
anderen Hunde, die Elitdog verkauft?
(Flüsternd) Chica.
Die Frau widerspricht sich.
Lässt dann
die angebliche Mutter bringen,
verglichen mit den Welpen
ist sie sehr klein.
Suchen wir also nach den Züchtern,
die Welpen an Elitdog verkauft haben.
Ich habe einige Adressen
zugespielt bekommen.
Mit dabei: Journalist Zolo Mikes.
Konntest du die Namen checken?
Was für Leute sind das?
Ich habe sie gecheckt.
Es sind keine normalen Züchter.
Sie vermehren die Hunde
nur als Nebenjob.
Was haben sie für Jobs?
Die arbeiten
in der Landwirtschaft
oder sind Chauffeure.
Es ist wahrscheinlich
ein schwarzes Nebengeschäft.
Vom Sitz von Elitdog aus
fahren wir durch die Südslowakei.
Zolo Mikes spricht
Slowakisch und Ungarisch.
Dobrý den.
* Hunde bellen. *
Jó napot kívánok.
Hier lebt ein Ehepaar, das schon
Welpen an Elitdog verkauft hat.
Die Frau sagt, sie hätten
einen neuen Wurf Malteser-Welpen.
Wir fragen,
ob wir die Hundemutter sehen können.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Sie möchten einen Hund kaufen,
und es ist wichtig für sie,
die Mutterhündin zu sehen.
Ich weiss nicht recht.
Zögerlich führt sie uns ins Haus.
Sie habe drei Muttertiere.
Zweimal im Jahr werden sie gedeckt.
Mehr ist biologisch
gar nicht möglich.
Bukshi!
Susi! Susi!
Die Frau missbraucht die Muttertiere
als Gebärmaschinen.
Die kontrollierte Schweizer Zucht
erlaubt nur einen Wurf pro Jahr.
Das ist Susi.
Bei Susi
sieht man die Zitzen eindeutig.
Hier also ist die Zucht,
zwischen Hinterhof und Haus.
Es stinkt nach Urin und Kot.
Die sechs Welpen
stammen von den drei Müttern.
Schlechte Würfe, sagt die Frau.
Und das habe seinen Grund.
Kitty erwürgt die Babys
der anderen Mütter.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Kitty und Bundi haben
zur gleichen Zeit Welpen bekommen.
Und innert einer Nacht hat Kitty
alle Welpen von Bundi getötet.
Wir nennen sie jetzt Killer Kitty.
Leider könne sie uns
keinen Welpen verkaufen.
Sie habe alle
einem Grosshändler versprochen.
Den Namen sagt sie nicht.
Er bezahle 250 Euro pro Hund.
Elitdog verkauft einen Malteser
für 1'000 Euro -
und mit Lieferung in die Schweiz
für 1'400.
Einmal hatte ich die Welpen
einem Händler versprochen.
Aber dann hat ein anderer
mehr Geld offeriert.
Ich habe die Tiere
dem Meistbietenden verkauft
und Ärger mit dem anderen gekriegt.
Es geht um viel Geld.
Die Welpen bringen
rund 5'000 Euro pro Jahr ein -
in dieser Gegend entspricht
das im Schnitt fünf Monatslöhnen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe Transportpapiere,
die zeigen,
dass Elitdog
viele Hunde in Ungarn aufkauft.
Teils sind sie in Ungarn
aber nicht registriert
und kommen illegal in die Slowakei.
Seit letztem Sommer aber gibt Elitdog
nur noch die eigene Firma
als Absender an
und verschleiert so,
wer die Welpen gezüchtet hat.
Wir fahren weiter
durch die Südslowakei.
Hier wahrscheinlich.
Auch der nächste Züchter
hat schon Welpen an Elitdog verkauft.
Guten Tag,
wir möchten einen Hund kaufen.
Dieser Mann bietet uns
zwei Golden Retriever an.
300 Euro pro Welpen.
Auch für einen Golden Retriever
verlangt Elitdog 1'000 Euro -
ohne Transport.
Insider sagten mir, Elitdog
kaufe Welpen schon ab 100 Euro auf.
Hat er auch Heimtierpässe? Oder wie
kriegen wir Hunde über die Grenze?
Ja, ja. Ich kann das organisieren.
Mein Freund ist Tierarzt.
Er hat Pässe und Mikrochips.
20 Euro komplett.
Ich frage nach ganz jungen Welpen.
Der Mann bringt
ein drei Wochen altes Tier.
Er hat ein Problem.
Er hat ein Loch im Kopf.
Ein Geburtsgebrechen.
Er entwickelt sich nicht gut.
Die neun Welpen wachsen
in dieser kleinen Stallbox auf.
Der Mann sagt, er sei arbeitslos.
Er lebe von der Zucht
von Hunden und Hühnern.
In der Slowakei gibt es keine
Obergrenze fürs Vermehren von Hunden.
Es wird darüber diskutiert,
pro Züchter maximal drei Hündinnen
zu erlauben.
Wir fahren weiter nach Ungarn,
stundenlang übers Land,
Richtung Rumänien.
Okay, schön.
Im Dorf Kaba treffen wir
auf ein auffallend schönes Haus.
Die Frau sagt, sie züchte Puli-Hunde,
eine spezielle ungarische Rasse.
Ihre Hunde
hätten schon Preise bekommen.
Wir können zu den Kleinen gehen.
* Sie spricht ungarisch. *
Die Welpen seien zwei Wochen alt.
In vier Wochen
können Sie sie abholen.
Und das ist für den Transport
in die Schweiz kein Problem,
dass sie zu jung sind,
dass etwas passieren kann, weil sie
nicht mehr bei der Mutter sind?
Kein Problem.
Die Welpen halten das schon aus.
Solche Transporte
wurden schon oft gemacht.
Die Preis-Züchterin
würde uns die Welpen mit sechs Wochen
also klar zu jung verkaufen.
Auch laut ungarischem Gesetz
sollten Welpen erst mit acht Wochen
von ihren Müttern getrennt werden.
Und das prämierte Muttertier
hat vermutlich eine Zwangsstörung,
sagen Spezialisten.
* Der Hund bellt und knurrt. *
Weiter in den Süden Ungarns.
Öcsöd ist 1 1/2 Std.
von der serbischen Grenze entfernt.
In Serbien gibt es noch Tollwut.
Auch von hier wurden schon Hunde
an Elitdog verkauft.
Eine Roma-Familie
zeigt uns französische Bulldoggen.
Er hat Atemprobleme.
Seine Nase ist zu eng.
Dazu starke Hautfalten
und verkrustete Ohren,
beides anfällig für Entzündungen.
Für ihn wollen sie 2'000 Euro.
Er sei lila und eine Merle-Zucht,
also gesprenkelt.
Beides heikle genetische Mutationen,
in der Schweizer Stammbaumzucht
nicht zugelassen.
Wir verlangen den Pass
des lila Welpen.
Geboren im Dezember 2020.
Nein, das ist das Impfdatum.
Kann er uns
auch andere Hunde beschaffen?
Zwergspitz oder Minimalteser?
Hat er da Connections?
Kein Problem.
Und weiter geht's
zur nächsten Familie.
Einmal hier hoch.
- Okay.
Auch sie wollen uns Welpen
schon mit sechs Wochen verkaufen.
Je jünger die Welpen,
desto weniger Geld
müssen sie für Futter ausgeben.
Und auch sie haben Merle-Sprenkel
und einen blauen Farbton.
Es besteht die Gefahr, dass die Tiere
erblinden oder taub werden.
Wenn Sie von der Seite schauen:
Der Hund hat keine Nase mehr.
Wahrscheinlich
sind die Nasenlöcher minim klein.
Deshalb können die Hunde
bei Hitze im Sommer
nicht spazieren geführt werden,
die kriegen keine Luft.
Die Hunde sehen ganz niedlich aus,
die grossen Augen,
das flache Näschen.
Das macht ein Babyface.
Und das spricht Menschen an.
Das ist ganz klare Qualzucht.
Die Hunde haben
keine lange Lebenserwartung.
Für mich ist das eine Welpenmafia,
um das ganz deutlich zu sagen.
Es wird vermehrt,
vermehrt, vermehrt.
Damit kann man
extrem gut Geld machen.
Wir haben hier ...
* Melancholische Klänge *
Das ist ein emotionaler Moment,
in dem man selbst denkt:
viel Einsatz und auch viel Einsatz
von Chica, der kleinen Maus.
Sie hat gekämpft und verloren.
Man fällt ein wenig zusammen.
Man kämpft die ganze Zeit.
Es ist spät abends, man gibt
sein Letztes, damit sie überleben.
Und dann geht es nicht so
wie gewünscht.
Oder wie erhofft.
Dann fällt man
ein bisschen in sich zusammen.
Resignation.
Es ist besonders schlimm,
wenn man Hunde verliert,
bei denen es
absolut unnötig gewesen wäre.
Wie jetzt bei ...
- Wie bei Welpenimporten.
Dieses Leiden der Hunde.
Chica war schwer krank.
Auch wenn wir sie behandeln und
Schmerzmittel und Infusionen geben -
das war für den Hund
kein Spaziergang.
Sie hatte eine Leidenszeit.
Diese wurde nicht mit Überleben
belohnt, sondern mit Tod beendet.
Das ist nichts Schönes.
Ich hatte zuerst die Besitzerin
am Telefon.
Die hat furchtbar geweint und das
Telefon an ihren Mann weitergegeben.
Und er war geschockt.
Elitdog habe zuerst nicht
auf die Anrufe der Familie reagiert.
Später dann habe die Firma angeboten,
einen neuen Hund zu schicken.
Würden Sie sagen, die Verantwortung
für diesen Tod liegt bei Elitdog,
die den Hund entweder gezüchtet
oder gekauft und transportiert hat?
Ich sehe das so, ja.
Kann man in diesem Fall die Firma
Elitdog haftbar machen für den Tod?
Was nützt es,
wenn Sie die Firma haftbar machen?
Chica bleibt tot.
Ausser, man könnte wirklich
strenge Strafen verhängen.
Entschuldigung,
wennich Sie unterbreche.
Für mich ist entscheidend:
Wenn man Hunde nicht bestellt
und kauft, haben sie keinen Markt.
Solange der Endverbraucher
den Hund bestellt, ist der Markt da.
Solange rechnet sich das
für jemanden, der keine Skrupel hat.
Bisher spielt der freie Markt.
Der Staat setzt
auf die Eigenverantwortung
der Konsumentinnen und Konsumenten.
Ob das aber reicht?
Denn: Chica ist kein Einzelfall.
Ich weiss von
drei weiteren Elitdog-Welpen,
die dieses Jahr
kurz nach dem Transport verstarben:
Nala, ein Labrador,
im Februar nahe Graz.
Ein Malteser auf
einem Elitdog-Transport im März,
der in Wien kontrolliert wurde.
Und Lucy, verstorben mitten
in der Nacht im Juli, in Niederhasli.
Ich wachte um 3.10 Uhr auf,
weil ich merkte,
dass irgendetwas nicht stimmte.
Sie schaute mich
mit ihren grossen Augen an,
atmete dreimal,
legte dann ihr Köpfchen
auf die linke Seite
und bewegte sich nicht mehr.
Sie starb in meinen Armen. Qualvoll.
Die Autopsie ergab:
Lucy verstarb an Parvovirose.
Zweieinhalb Tage
nach dem Transport.
Mit grosser Wahrscheinlichkeit
hatte sie sich
schon vor der Reise infiziert.
Wie war die Reaktion von Elitdog,
als Sie anriefen?
Kalt, abweisend.
Sie wollten uns die Schuld geben.
Quasi: Sie hätten den Hund
verkauft und geliefert,
der Rest sei unser Problem.
Es ging ihnen am Arsch vorbei,
ob der Hund überlebt oder nicht.
Für sie ist das eine Handelsware.
Zusammen
mit einer ungarischen Übersetzerin
kontaktiere ich den Chef von Elitdog.
Herr T. bestreitet die Todesfälle
vehement.
(Chef) Glauben Sie nicht eher,
dass ein illegaler Hundehändler
aus der Slowakei oder Ungarn
diese Fälle verursacht hat?
Und dass er uns das in die Schuhe
schiebt, um uns zu schaden?
Nein, diese Hunde
wurden bei Elitdog bestellt.
Wie kann das sein?
Es ist nicht wahr!
Es ist nicht wahr.
Wir haben
mit den Besitzern gesprochen.
Wir haben die Tiere gesehen.
Die Schweizer mögen unsere Hunde.
Schatzi, ich sage die Wahrheit:
Die Hundekäufer
lassen ihren Welpen bei -5 °C
in einer kalten Pfütze spielen,
und wenn die Tiere dann sterben,
was kann ich dafür?
Aber immer heisst es:
Das Parvovirus ist das Problem,
das Parvovirus, das Parvovirus.
In der Slowakei sind Grosshändler
wie Herr T. auf Tierärzte angewiesen.
Ein einziger Tierarzt
hat in den letzten Jahren
Tausende Pässe für Elitdog-Welpen
unterschrieben:
Doktor K.
Wir suchen seine Praxis auf.
Guten Tag, wir suchen Doktor K.
(Frau) Er ist nicht zu Hause.
Die Frau von K.
gibt uns seine Telefonnummer.
Wir sollen ihn anrufen.
* Freizeichen *
Ich rufe an, weil das
Schweizer Fernsehen Dokumente hat,
die beweisen,
dass Hundepässe gefälscht sind.
Pässe, die Sie unterschrieben haben.
"Unmöglich", sagt Doktor K.
Heimtierpässe seien fälschungssicher.
Unsere Papiere aber
zeigen das Gegenteil.
Ex-Geschäftspartner von Elitdog
sagen,
Tierärzte hätten Blanko-Pässe
an Elitdog verkauft.
Doktor K. bestreitet das.
Was weiss und macht die staatliche
Veterinärbehörde gegen Elitdog?
In Bratislava erfahren wir:
Der Name der Firma ist bekannt.
Im Juli sei sie letztmals
kontrolliert worden,
sagt Veterinärchef Jozef Bires.
Es gab mehrere Probleme.
Die Transportpapiere
waren nicht in Ordnung.
Die Zuchtbedingungen waren nicht gut
und die Impfungen nicht korrekt:
Zwar wurde geimpft,
aber nach der Tollwutimpfung
muss man drei Wochen warten,
bis die Impfung wirkt.
Diese Frist wurde nicht abgewartet.
Die Hunde wurden zu früh exportiert.
Ausserdem konnten wir nicht klären,
von welchen Züchtern
die Hunde stammen.
Es drohen Bussen.
2011 habe man die Firma
letztmals gebüsst - mit 350 Euro.
Tierarzt K. sei nie gebüsst worden.
Fehlbare Tierärzte aber
kämen in eine Risikogruppe
und würden regelmässig kontrolliert.
Wie viele haben
die in der Risikogruppe?
Das kann ich Ihnen
nicht genau sagen.
Aber ich denke, es ist eine Gruppe
von ca. 50 Personen.
Es sind ungefähr 50.
50 Veterinärärzte?
Das ist ein grosses Problem.
Nein, das ist wirksame Kontrolle.
Der Fall Elitdog
spielt sich in Dunajská Streda ab,
einem Bezirk in der Südslowakei.
Die regionale Veterinärbehörde müsste
jeden Hund, der ins Ausland fährt,
vor dem Transport
auf seine Gesundheit überprüfen.
Warum fällt bei fast 1'000 exportier-
ten Hunden letztes Jahr nichts auf?
Insider vermuten Korruption.
Wir rufen den Amtstierarzt an,
der die meisten Elitdog-Hunde vor
dem Transport für gesund erklärt hat.
Könnten Sie uns ein Interview geben
zum Hundehandel, heute oder morgen?
Ich bin nicht zuständig.
Auf keinen Fall.
Könnten Sie uns etwas sagen
zur Passfälschung der Firma Taktik?
* Mehrfacher Piepston *
Aufgelegt.
"Auf keinen Fall",
und dann legt er auf?
"Ich bin nicht zuständig."
Und was schliesst du daraus?
Dass er vielleicht einen Anruf
bekommen hat von ...* Piepston *
Vom Tierarzt?
- Vermutlich.
Würden Sie Korruption
in Dunajská Streda ausschliessen?
Es gibt Hinweise auf gewisse Leute,
aber es ist nichts Konkretes.
Wenn es konkret ist,
werdeich dieses Problem lösen.
Aber die Frage ist:
Haben Sie selber
bisher genug unternommen?
Ich?
In Bezug auf Kontrolle?
Wir müssen die Kontrolle verstärken.
D.h., bisher wurde zu wenig gemacht,
wenn Sie die Kontrolle
verstärken wollen?
Wir bieten Risikoanalysen.
Ja oder nein?
Denken Sie,
dass Sie mehr tun müssten?
Mehr, immer mehr.
Wir zeigen ihm die Fälschungen.
Die Schweizer Kantonstierärzte
haben von Mitte 2019
bis Anfang dieses Jahres
350 Unregelmässigkeiten
bei 500 Elitdog-Fällen gefunden.
Das ist neu für mich.
Sind Sie besorgt?
Yes.
Wenn sich die 350 Fälle bestätigen,
dann ist das ein Grund,
die Firma zu schliessen.
Aber ich brauche die einzelnen Fälle
von Ihrem Land.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Was also läuft
beim Bundesamt für Veterinärwesen?
Hier wurden
die manipulierten Elitdog-Fälle
aus der ganzen Schweiz gesammelt.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt
gegen die Firma Elitdog?
Wir haben Strafanzeige
bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
St. Gallen eingereicht.
Was nützt eine Strafanzeige in St.
Gallen gegen eine ausländische Firma?
Leider wenig.
Hat die Schweiz die 350 Fälle
der Slowakei gemeldet?
Nein,
sagt die Tierschutzverantwortliche.
Mir haben im Tierschutzgesetz
keine gesetzliche Grundlage,
um Daten weiterzugeben.
Wenn Sie mit einer Firma
unzufrieden sind,
die immer wieder Pässe
manipuliert oder fälscht,
dürfen Sie die Veterinärbehörde
dieses Landes nicht anrufen
und ihr die Fälle mitteilen,
sodass die im Land
dagegen vorgehen können?
Eigentlich nicht.
Das ist ja skandalös.
Das müsste man wenn möglich ...
Es bräuchte eine Gesetzesänderung.
Datenschutz
wird immer sehr hoch gewertet.
Selbst bei Firmen,
die illegal vorgehen?
Dort überwiegt im Moment
der Datenschutz den Tierschutz.
Ich informiere Liv Sigg
über mein Gespräch mit dem Chef
der slowakischen Veterinärbehörde.
Er sagte mir, dass er dringend
die Fälle aus der Schweiz brauche.
Bei 350 Fällen
könne man die Firma schliessen.
Dann muss er
bei uns ein Amtshilfegesuch stellen.
Dann kann man es wieder probieren.
Sie können das nicht von sich aus?
Frau Sigg, ich gebe Ihnen hier
die entsprechenden Kontaktdaten.
Das ist super.
Sie haben ihn noch nie angerufen?
Nein, in meiner Position
rufe ich nicht dem Generaldirektor
der Slowakei an.
Wieso nicht?
Mit mir hat er auch geredet.
Wenn Sie mir sagen, dass er sich
über eine Kontaktaufnahme freut,
dann schon.
Aber wenn man hier Probleme sieht,
ist das nicht der übliche Weg.
Als ich sie eine Woche
später nochmals anrufe, heisst es,
man wolle zuerst die Straf-
untersuchung in der Schweiz abwarten.
Wir machen eine Kontrolle.
Nehmen Sie bitte Geld und Telefon
mit und kommen Sie mit uns rein.
Verstehen Sie mich?
Nicht?
Geld, Telefon, Kontrolle.
Kommen Sie mit mir mit.
Es ist frühmorgens
an einem Freitag Ende August.
Ein Transport von Elitdog
wird kontrolliert.
Wie viele Hunde haben Sie dabei?
* Eine Dolmetscherin übersetzt. *
(Dolmetscherin) Acht.
Von wo sind die Hunde?
Aus der Slowakei.
Alle aus der Slowakei.
Diesmal wurden die Pässe der Welpen
nicht manipuliert.
Geburtsdaten und Impfungen
sind nur einmal eingetragen.
Stimmen die Papiere?
Das stimmt,
es sind genau die vorliegenden.
Sind das alles slowakische Pässe?
- Ja.
Ich habe zu dieser Firma
recherchiert.
Teils kommen die Hunde aus Ungarn,
sind dort aber nicht registriert
und bekommen erst
in der Slowakei Pässe.
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen.
Wir bekommen immer
die slowakischen Pässe dazu.
Diese Nummer tragen wir ein
in den Chip, den die Hunde haben.
Das geben wir bei der Verzollung an.
Ja, ja. Ja.
Schwierig. Oje.
Auch Matthias Diener ist hier,
der Amtstierarzt,
der Anfang Jahr Elitdog-Welpen
wegen Fälschungen beschlagnahmt hat.
Worauf achten Sie?
Ich schaue die Augen an -
ob die tränenden Ausfluss haben.
Und ob die Farbe okay ist.
Ob man die Gefässe
in der Sklera sieht.
Dann schaue ich die Zähne an.
Die brechen gerade durch.
Das heisst?
Der ist noch keine drei Monate alt,
aber etwa acht Wochen.
Das würde etwa passen.
Schauen wir, ob er Durchfall hat.
Hat er nicht. Das ist gut.
Die Augen sind auch okay?
- Ja.
Herr Diener,
eine grundsätzliche Frage:
Alle Experten sagten mir,
acht Wochen seien gesetzlich okay,
aber die Tiere seien einfach zu jung.
Macht sich die Schweiz mitschuldig
mit diesem Gesetz,
dass die Tiere krank werden?
Diese Frage
kann ich nicht beantworten.
Ich setze das Gesetz um,
das im Moment gilt.
Aber was ist Ihre Meinung?
Es ist sicher nicht gut,
wenn die Hunde schon so jung
transportiert werden.
Der Bund prüft jetzt,
ob das Mindestalter bei Import-Welpen
erhöht werden soll.
Polizeibilder
eines Elitdog-Transports,
der letzten Herbst
in Tirol gestoppt wurde:
sechs von neun Welpen zu jung
und einige auch krank.
Auf der Fahrt
zu wenig gefüttert und getränkt.
Meine Recherchen ergeben:
Diese Chauffeure
mussten Bussen bezahlen
und haben damit den Tatbestand
der Tierquälerei anerkannt.
Sie haben sechs Welpen
über längere Zeit
einem qualvollen Zustand ausgesetzt,
weil Sie sie zu wenig
gefüttert und getränkt haben.
Ist das Quälerei?
Wenn ein Hund Durchfall hat
und der Tierarzt sagt,
er ist transportfähig,
was sollen wir dann machen?
In Österreich bei dieser Strafe ...
Mit einem Deutschen
würden Sie nicht so sprechen.
Der würde sich Ihre Vorwürfe
nicht bieten lassen.
Sie können es ja erklären ...
Ich habe genug.
Es geht mir auf die Nerven.
Die Busse haben Sie gekriegt,
weil Sie die Tiere zu wenig getränkt
und zu wenig gefüttert haben.
Das ist nicht normal.
Verdammt noch mal!
Wieso wird nicht einfach der
Onlinehandel von Welpen verboten?
Ein Tier
ist kein Zalando-Kleidungsstück.
Absolut meine Meinung.
Wieso verbietet man das nicht?
Aber wer will den Konsumentinnen
und Konsumenten schon vorschreiben,
was sie kaufen dürfen und was nicht?
Also hätte ein Verbot keine Chance?
Aufgrund des Tierschutzs
und des Tierwohls
hätten wir vielleicht schon
eine Chance. Das muss man anpacken.
Nicht nur in der Schweiz,
sondern international.
* Fiepen *
* Hohes Bellen *
Bye bye.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2021